hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in chapters seven and ten of his
treatise on truth the day veritante
anselm of canterbury is going to now
redirect us back to thinking about the
highest truth that is god and also
thinking about the totality of beings
you could say
the
ascentia or existencia
of everything else besides god that has
being that is
and there's a lot of you could say
rather deep metaphysics going on here
being in some respects kind of
offhandedly
discussed and so that's something that
we want to work our way through
and in the very beginning of
chapter 7 he says consider whether apart
from the highest truth truth might be
understood to be in anything besides
what we have already
looked into and a student says what
could that be and he says
do you think that anything could be at
any time or any place that was not in
this highest truth the highest truth of
course is god and that did not receive
what it is insofar as it is or that it
could be something else than what it now
is and the student says well that's
unthinkable so what is he talking about
there he's saying everything that is
everything that has being is in a
certain way in the highest truth it
doesn't just merely participate in truth
it's in
truth itself
and he says that it receives
a kipparrit
it receives its being it receives what
it is quote asked
in so far
qua in quantum
you know is the latin for that that it
is so
whatever degree of being
things have they have ultimately
from
being in the supreme truth being in god
and he goes on and he's going to say
that
this leads us to being able to make some
declarations
he says that something truly is
insofar as it is
what it is
there in the
supreme truth right in quantum eb est eb
is there
so it's not just
insofar as it has being
it has its greatest being and this is
kind of a trippy idea
within the supreme truth not actually
even within itself and this is an idea
that he unpacked in the monologuine
which is being referenced earlier so
what does this give us this gives us
sort of a metaphysics where we have
things that that exist like you and me
or chalkboards or shoes or pick whatever
you like and then there's god the
supreme truth and things are in that but
notice that this chapter title
is about the
essentia the being or essence
of
things
right
so there is truth then and some says
in the essence or being of all things
omni sunt essentia now it should be
omnia
except for god right
the essence or the being because essence
doesn't mean
hear and ansem what it typically means
in other thinkers like the what it is of
the thing or how we define it you know
leaving aside accidental properties the
essence the essentia is what that being
is period and then the existencia is
going to be even going beyond that but
so everything that is the the the
essence the being not just of each
individual thing
but of the totality of created being
all of this
has truth
why because each of the things
are what they are in swent in latin
what they are in the supreme truth now
we might be tempted here to say well
that makes it sound like god is actually
you know as the supreme truth also the
essence of things and
anselm doesn't want to endorse that
because there is this essence of of
created being you could say
but god is beyond that god is even more
metaphysically
basic superior however you want to
frame it and he goes on and he talks
about each of these
things that are
as
being true right he says um
[Music]
is anything uh if anything ought to be
otherwise than it is in the highest
truth and he says therefore if all
things are what they are there they are
without doubt what they ought to be
and the student says they are truly what
they ought to be and whatever is what it
ought to be exists or has being rightly
recta so it has rectitudano that is
rightness or rectitude of whatever it is
which is truth right so
this is a really important attainment
that happens within chapter
seven of on truth so he goes on and says
if truth and rectitude are in the
essence of things
because they are that which they are in
the highest truth
it's certain that the truth of things is
rectitude so we've got
being what they are in the highest truth
being in the essence of things and then
their individual being you could say if
we unpack this a little bit further
when we turn to chapter 10
the terminology
is going to change slightly but you'll
notice that it's not anselm himself who
is making this
switch but his student
that's placed in the student's mouth so
anselm says you will not deny that the
highest truth is
rectitude and then he's going to bring
up issues of causality cause and effect
he says
consider that since all the foregoing
all the rectitudes we've discussed up
until this point
are be are such because they are in
things which are or do what they ought
does this apply to the highest truth
well the highest truth
doesn't have an ought like that it's not
like god or the highest truth is subject
to something yet higher that says you
ought to be this way i mean we human
beings sometimes reason about god
as if we're going to tell god how god
ought to be
but you know that's because we get a
little bit too big for our britches
intellectually and forget that we are
you know only getting part of the
picture and that we don't compel god so
he goes on and he says the highest truth
is not rectitude because it owes
anything all other truths oh that
highest truth but he owes nothing to
another nor is there any reason why god
is
as he is and then he brings up causality
and he says
this rectitude god the highest truth is
the cause of all other truth and
rectitude but nothing
is the cause of that and then the
student says something kind of
interesting he says all right yeah i get
that
i see that when it comes to other things
besides god
some of them
are just effects
right so there's a cause for them
and then they are effects and they don't
make anything else happen although you
know they could make something else
happen
but we're going to say that they don't
and then there's other things that are
effects but there are also causes for
other things
and those are getting you know getting
us a little bit closer to the supreme
truth
so
he's going to talk here about the
truth
that is in the existence
of
things
in
existencia now notice
in both cases we have in you know in
raid room or ray room right
um
we've got existencia we've got essentia
what's the difference between them uh in
anselm's work
existencia is often used um
to signify
that there's like a greater intensity of
being or something like that so for
example the famous so-called ontological
argument in prosology and book two
concludes by saying not that deus it or
deus essay but deus existed right
truly
so you know what is this adding it's a
little bit difficult to say there it's
sort of like an emphasis right so what
we have is
the being of things the their existence
is
truth and it's the cause of for example
as the student is going to suggest
an anselm is going to say well done
right the the he says the truth that's
in the things that exist or the
existence of things is the effect of
the highest truth but it's also the
cause
of the truth which is in knowledge
and of that which is in the statement
but these two truths are not the cause
of any other truth themselves so our
capacity
to be able to speak the world or
think the world or ourselves
is the effect of the existence of the
totality of beings
and that itself is the effect of
the highest truth
so you know highest truth
existence or
essence or being of things
uh
true you know
language thought maybe will action all
these other things that we talk about
signification
there's sort of a hierarchy here
going on and so what we ought to be
doing if we want to fully understand
what's what's going on here in the on
truth and also and someone saying in the
monologian
we want to direct our
gaze
no longer you know
not away from all these other kinds of
truth but towards
the highest truth that helps us to
understand
where all these other truths are
originating from and how they are
structured where they are getting their
rectitude or rightness
from as the cause
to their being as effects
you